I am here with my great friend Kevin
O'Leary and we are in the beautiful
Muskoka is on Lake joseph' and we're
going for a little boat cruise and we're
going to talk about real estate
especially cottage real estate and also
all the things that Kevin's up to which
is a lot so Kevin I call cottaging like
the next thing like I guess hockey is to
Canadians
everybody aspires to own that other
place where they can have great family
time and memories but I know your
opinion in terms of an investment well
look I mean I sit here with you in a day
like today cruising in this boat across
this beautiful lake there's no place
like it on earth and so when you start
to attribute that value to why you would
buy a cottage you can understand why
people put such a huge number on these
places you even though it's a really a
three month phenomenon people love it up
here as I do as you do I mean this is
truly the essence of being Canadian you
can dive in this water and drink it
where else on earth can you do that so
yes I like cottage investments however
you've got to have your eyes open when
you're going into this because the truth
is for most of these cottages they're
not bought as investment properties they
end up being a huge financial expense
every year to the people that own them
there's no property I own that cost me
more than this place does because my
wife goes nuts every year renovating it
but not a choice right yeah it is it's a
lifestyle choice but I don't I don't
want people to invest in cottages
thinking that that is the best asset
class of real estate it is for family it
is for enjoying your life but it is not
the best in terms of capital
appreciation so let's talk more about
that for a second because people that
bought cottages in the 60s and 70s they
have never seen such appreciation I mean
they really are benefitting today and
even people now that okay I agree me too
that maybe bought in 2005 to 2008
they're trying to possibly sell and
they're not able to recoup what they pay
for they bought in the height of the
market but there's still an opportunity
and we're not just talking with Stoke
abut of other lakes and other waterfront
areas going now north or west or east
where you can pick up great cottages
remote areas beautiful lakes and even
they will probably appreciate over the
long term so would you say is a long
term
hold it's something that you could
advise that would be a great investment
yeah you've hit on the real issue
because if you're going to buy a cottage
to flip it as as a trade that's not
gonna work for you because I agree with
you people that bought 2007-2008 I still
think they're underwater but if you take
the cottage on into the family portfolio
of what matters in your life that makes
sense because anybody that bought any
property 25 years ago 20 years ago in
this area and all the surrounding lakes
has made a ton of money and you have to
make the assumption over the next two
decades the same will occur and I
generally do endorse that the question
is can you support the taxes the
maintenance and the costs of being in
that cottage the next 20 years that's
the decision you have to make now so the
advice you're talking about is when
you're trying to choose if you want a
cottage it's making sure that if it's if
it's a lifestyle that you want you have
a little extra cash that you can afford
to do it most likely getting a mortgage
which we'll talk about in a second your
company but it's about making sure you
go somewhere that is affordable
understanding all the costs that are
involved in ownership yes and I think
cottages have to be taken on as part of
what I call the family nut there is
going to be a financial monthly cost
maintaining in taxes being the number
one and number two of what you're gonna
be paying and if you're on forage for
that and you can fit that in your
lifestyle it is the most wonderful
investment you can make in your life
just look at this point so let's go to
the mortgage side of things for a second
all right now you have your new company
so mortgages okay so leary mortgages do
you help people when it comes to wanting
cottages I call these kinds of mortgages
entrepreneurial mortgages in the sense
that most banks won't do them some banks
will do cottages others won't
that's right the truth is you need a lot
of equity if you're gonna get a mortgage
for a cottage you know be ready to put
up to 25 percent of X sometimes 35 and
islands you could be as high as 60 right
yeah because it's almost impossible to
get a mortgage on an island there's all
kinds of issues with that but maybe if
you're 50% equity you can do it we look
at these loans on a one-on-one basis and
we're just looking at the individual
what other assets if you're gonna
mortgage you have to be ready for the
volatility of the
because as you know in a down-cycle they
could appreciate 30% and you can get a
no-bid situation cottage like this one
across the lake here if they want to
sell it tomorrow they may not be able to
get liquid for two years to take years
to stand a lender looks at that and says
I have to adjust my risk accordingly his
mortgage as part of your strategy for
investing in cottages it's not an easy
road at all I can give you many examples
of people have tried to buy cottages in
the sort of two to five million dollar
range that we're not able to get a
mortgage at all it's not from lack of
qualification it's more from the lenders
worried about little in debt itself the
lenders are pulling their horns in to
assets like this because the assumption
is and clearly we can talk about this we
are in a rising rate environment on
mortgages they've gone up 33 percent in
five months and you know you don't see
2.7 6 % anymore and you would never see
that on the cottage we're north of three
and a half three seven which is still
fantastic it is but but you can't get
those loans for cottages looking at a
five year on a cottage I think you have
to be ready to be over five percent if
you can get it and the lenders like me
and many others that I compete with if
we're gonna look at a portfolio like
this we spend a whole lot of time going
into the file because we know the
liquidity risk is huge that's the
problem what it is interesting Kevin
though a lot of banks are actually now
because the popularity of cottaging
they've started to treat cottaging as if
they are like homes a lot of people as
you know are downsizing in the city
they're taking that McMansion getting
something smaller cashing in on the
money that they made from selling that
monster and they're taking that money in
the capital and bringing it up into
cottage country where they like to spend
their quality time for the eventualities
of retiring in this area so as a result
the banks are cut to kind of wise up so
somebody that's done a lot of real
estate up here and a lot of mortgages
and help people get their financing in
order it has become a heck of a lot
easier and especially within the last
five years now with the way things are
going what's your prediction in terms of
the economy and what we're going to be
expecting in the years to come
well let's go back to the issue of the
mortgage if you can convince a lander
that you're eventually turning your car
your primary residence they may buy that
story and be far more open to the idea
of funding a material mortgage and I
mean something more than a million
dollars that can happen because there is
a trend for people to move here and live
their lives here because there's a lot
of good attributes to that I would say
that's at the beginning maybe in the
first or second inning in terms of
liquidity of mortgages up here but
you're right that is a trend and over
the next 20 years it's gonna play itself
out there's no question they're building
the new ones as if they are primary
homes also every cottage that's built on
this lake now has better systems
controls and construction quality than
the primary residents had built 10 years
ago I agree with that we will see some
kind of a correction in real estate but
not be as as damaging as it was before
in other words I remember cycles after
seven years we lost 30 percent right and
then you have to wait another decade to
get back to even we never had that
problem here but the government clarity
the new policies analyzation schedules
in 30 down to 25 obviously a 33 percent
increase in rates and primary residences
all these are headwinds their tell-tale
signs are things they can't fight city
hall
you can't fight a rising rate
environment my best case scenario for
real estate including cottages for the
next five years is flat that's what I
think and then you're gonna get this
rapid period of appreciation when people
feel ok rates have to stop going up
let's and I'm calling for a 200 basis
point rate hike over the next three
years once a period from 2003 to 2007 we
had 200 basis points 2% increase very
slowly I think it's gonna happen again
and I can see it in the fund flows in
O'Leary funds which is a great barometer
it is a great problem so right now
people are pulling their horns in from
bond funds and putting more money into
floating rate funds our fastest growing
fund right now is our Laurie O'Leary
floating rate fund which gives you more
cash every month if rates go up it's a
protection against inflation and that is
a paramount on everybody's mind and so
when I you know two months ago let's say
a ticket came in for a hundred thousand
dollars it would be all the Canadian
bond fund today it's half the Canadian
bond fund half floating rate and that
just happened the last two weeks
that's how fast
yeah Kevin thank you so much for your
time today and the boat ride well that
was just awesome
you